[Music]
hey everybody
it's sunday yeah and it's august first
yeah
you're going i'm going all gentle with
that i thought that might have been your
your your radio voice your npr voice
well because when i'm in
when i'm enthusiastic you you make fun
of me
so i thought i'd change it up a little
bit so i didn't get made fun of for a
chance
to tease it
but yeah it's august 1st today so you
know it's like the hottest month in
florida but
um you know the sooner august comes the
sooner august will be over
and then it will be september and then
it will be halloween yeah it's the dead
of summer
which you know dead of summer fall can't
come quick enough even though it won't
be
that much cooler but it does cool down
though a little bit close down
a little bit at night yeah in in
the end of this month it'll still be
pretty hot the month after that will be
pretty hot but not as hot as this month
it does start to cool yeah like i said
it's kind of gradual and then all of a
sudden all of a sudden have real cool
days
yeah it'll be hot and then you have like
three days
of cool and then it gets hot again yeah
and then like two or three days of cool
and then it gets four days hot
just kind of comes and yeah this goes
what it is
here i mean yeah it's mostly just yeah
hot all the time
i've been standing outside boiling hot
and all of a sudden a cool wind goes and
blows the whole [ __ ]
heat away and it's cold for days
that's easy because the storm's coming
yeah but uh
it'll be hot and it's like somebody's
tripped a switch
you'll get hit with a cold blast of wind
and it'll be cold for days
well not cold but cool like in the 70s
in the 60s
yeah which is comparatively
comparatively it feels like whoa man
granthar's hammer said cool breeze today
in michigan wow that must be nice
it should it kind of it rained earlier
here like it wasn't like a really bad
storm but i think it was up in the 90s
and then
there was a little bit of rain now it
says 89 and it says mostly sunny went
out last night
yeah i just went to mannequins for a
little while mundanes
there's a lot of basic [ __ ] there
there really were
they said friday was fantastic though
yeah we should have gone
well to the blood fest what was it
called a blood bath blood bath yeah yeah
well we should well uh you know there's
fake blood everywhere still on the walls
and [ __ ]
yeah well yeah
i mean you know they said it was
everywhere but i didn't yeah
yeah but that's the thing well you know
it's like we could have gone friday
night but i was just so [ __ ] tired
yeah you know what i mean i've been up
since like 5 30 in the morning and it's
like
then we did the show that was three or
four hours and i was just kind of like
man i'm just so [ __ ] sleepy
yeah i just i'm always sleeping all
right three teddy yuma
saw for the first time somebody sent it
to us one of you guys sent it to us i
think it might have been a louis
oh yeah it might have been um so yeah i
didn't realize because i think esther
was just saying in the comments that she
likes the original
better uh this is actually the second
adaptation
of a short story by elmore leonard
that came out in 1953 and so they made a
movie version of it back in 1957
which i've heard is very good but i
haven't seen it yeah uh but yeah so this
is the second uh
one and this was directed by james
mangold who did ford v ferrari
um he did logan walk the line
cop land yeah uh girl interrupted i
think he did awesome i haven't seen
copland that's supposed to be good
oh i liked it a lot i haven't seen it i
saw it in the theater i think when it
came out it's like a while back fast
alone
yeah yeah he got fat for that role yeah
i should see that one he pudged you'd
probably like it i remember it being
really really good
yeah ford versus ford versus ferrari is
a masterpiece
yeah i loved that movie that was that
was really really great
but yeah so it's the same director as
this this came out in 2007
2007 and um i have to say like i'm not
like westerns aren't my favorite genre
but man this was a really good movie
this is a really good movie
it's pretty good i liked it it's kind of
like in the uh
kind of like uh you know kind of like a
you know like a sergio leone type
spaghetti western type
yeah they're good you know good bad the
ugly type of deal but it had a
kind of a kind of had an interesting
story
about bravery and trying to live up uh
trying to live up in the memory of your
boy sacrificing your life to be a good
example
you know trying to save your your honor
it has some pretty good themes in it i
liked it yeah i really liked that i
liked the juxtaposition between
um christian bale who plays like the
good guy
and then russell crowe who plays the bad
guy he's like the outlaw
but then russell crowe's character ben
wade he's actually
he's kind of a good guy too though sort
of but i mean he he's really like um
he's a really interesting like charming
compelling character which makes him
like a really good
antagonist i guess um
and i really i just liked the way the
two of them like played off each other
because it's it's funny because poor
christian bale's character
whose name is dan right dan evans and
he's just really been
you know kicked in the balls by life
pretty much
i mean he was in the civil war uh he got
his foot shot off right yeah by his own
by his own guys so it's like not even
nobody knows that though that's a secret
yeah because well yeah because
you know he wanted it to be like oh he
was in the war and he got wounded in the
war but it was just like it happened in
like a stupid way it was like friendly
yeah and so he got his foot shot off and
then like he's got a wife and a couple
sons
and they live on this farm there's a
really bad drought
uh they're really behind on their debts
um you know so he's just like trying to
be a good guy and trying to like provide
for his family but it's just kind of
like all these things are conspiring
against him so it's like you know he
he borrows like all this money from that
hollander dude right and then at the
beginning like hollander comes and it's
like hey
[ __ ] you and like let's all his [ __ ]
cows out and then like burns his barn
down and [ __ ] like that just to be a
dick
and they're like yeah i'm gonna burn
your house down if you don't like pay
your debts back and blah blah
so that's kind of how uh dan
gets roped into what doesn't get roped
into it he kind of volunteers
um they're trying to find because he
meets up with
ben wade and his gang you know they're
robbing a stagecoach and they killed
pretty much everybody except for one
dude yeah they were
killing they they fought a bunch of
pinkertons yeah yeah yeah and some
people don't know what pinkertons are
but if you don't know what a pinkerton
is
back in the 1800s the ultimate law
enforcement
agency that was around in the united
states was a private security company
called the pinkerton
we call pinkerton's investigation
picketing security
i think it was investigation or
something i've been wanting to do a show
about them actually
they were so good of course that they um
they were hired by all the presidents
they were the secret service for the
president
they were across the president of the
united states would hire them as kind of
like secret service
and i also did things that kind of like
the fbi would do
and they would also do things that like
uh
delta force would do today yeah and they
had spies
and some of them were female it was the
pinkerton agency was was fascinating
you can make a whole movie just on that
agency
and it didn't play by any rules
they they recruited guys from
law enforcement military and convicted
criminals
and prostitutes and
just they got talent wherever the talent
was
they didn't care as long as they felt
they could trust you and you were
talented you could go work for
pinkertons
um which that's kind of like
one of the one of the big parts in this
one of the big elements in this movie is
this
that this bad guy this train robber
i guess he's not just a train robber
he's everything he's just an outlaw
yeah and he's super famous like
everybody knows who this dude is he's a
really good gun
fighter and uh he's real treacherous
organized criminal oracle says there's a
pinkerton series on netflix based on the
real cases oh that's right
we would just have to watch that
actually i didn't even know that was not
there's so much stuff on netflix it's
like it's
stuff gets buried you know yeah i didn't
know that i didn't i didn't know that
either i see that yeah we'll have to
watch that
um what i was getting at was
the good guys in this movie that are
after this bad guy once they catch him
he kind of exposes all these so-called
good guys he knows their history and
where they came from
he didn't like pinkerton's he didn't
like cops
um back in this era
chances are your your sheriff said his
deputies they also had criminal
pasts too because there was no
way to keep track anybody's true
identity you can change your name move
to another state and change your name
and nobody knew jack [ __ ]
they didn't even have fingerprint
technology you could claim to be about
anybody
and if you want to go after criminals
you're best [ __ ] hiring guys that
know how criminals think
which is an honest criminal somebody who
used to be a criminal you can trust him
you know he'll work for money and he'll
you know go after another criminal
because a milk toast type dude doesn't
have this
the knowledge and the skills that a
criminal would have like where to hide
and who's who
in the underworld and stuff so unless
you kind of know how to think like you
know
i think like you go where would i go
what would i do yeah and it's that kind
of stuff
now you don't really necessarily need
that
you know that kind of talent today
because of modern technology but back in
those days you did
and uh they didn't have the concept of
felon back then
a guy could do time and when he got out
his
he was a full-fledged citizen again he
could go buy guns he could do whatever
he wanted
uh so he could join the cops now if he
was a really bad
guy he would never get out of prison
because they'd hate him
yeah because they hung people for pretty
minor stuff well
stealing a horse was basically attempted
murder so they hug you for that
yeah because you stole somebody's horse
out from underneath them in the west
that was killing them essentially yeah
and
they had but they also did a thing for
stealing
cattle but stealing in a way
is attempted murder in the west because
everybody needed
every [ __ ] thing that they had yeah
that was then some of their like the
cattle and stuff that was your
livelihood that's your livelihood
so you take them from the people and
they're gonna stay taking money from
people and cows from people is the same
with taking life from people
you know they couldn't pay their bills
and bad [ __ ] would happen to them
so if a guy got out of prison chances
he was eligible to become a cop yeah
because if he was really bad or really
bad he'd have been dead
they'd they'd hung him um
an example would be john wesley hard he
killed a whole bunch of dudes
in gun fights but it was considered to
be self-defense they were trying to kill
him
yeah they were trying to kill each other
back then all right
he got out of prison and became a lawyer
and so he was an attorney
you know a lot of people don't know that
john wesley harden [ __ ] killed they
say he shot a man for snoring
which there's more to that story than
that oh esther said jenny your shirt is
awesome thank you i just got i just got
it yesterday yeah
i was i was very excited but i saw this
like i was like oh my god i have to have
that
shot a man for snoring but it was an
accident it was on the other side of a
wall there was a dude snoring over there
they were all drunk he shot
at the wall the next day shut up yeah he
did it while he was drunk and half
asleep
shot the wall with a bullet went through
and hit the guy in his sleep and killed
him
well lucy quieted him down though didn't
you heart rolled back over and fell
asleep
he found the body and woke him up and he
was in bed with a pistol [ __ ]
sleeping
he said you killed a man he goes no i
didn't because i just shot the wall he
was snoring
he killed him and it was an accident
he he it was an accidental homicide he
didn't even do in time for that
but if i remember correctly but the uh
he got out became a member of the court
so that's just the way it was back then
and these dudes and
these dudes are trying to hunt down this
wanted criminal with this wanted
criminal
who goes yeah well he was killing women
and children [ __ ] his cheyenne women and
children just a couple
years ago on a job for somebody other
you know
wiped out a whole bunch of people he
knows well they were scalping people no
they were apaches as they were
they were scalping railroad workers
though so you know it's just
everything everything was gray every
everybody in this movie
except except the good guy
even he might be kind of gray
it's not so black and white although he
was kind of like i think they
the reason that they had that was
because they were showing like christian
bale's character
who was like the only one that did the
right thing
every time even when it didn't benefit
him and
actually even when it actively like
[ __ ] him in the ass
yeah that's right he was the only guy
that actually kind of had honor
yeah yeah because he always did the
right thing like like i said even though
his whole life like you know life was
just [ __ ] on him all the time
and his son particularly his older son
who was kind of an [ __ ]
um didn't really respect him you know
just but he thought he was weak
you know and it's like you know he's
broke and it's like he's you know so
and he couldn't like stop um you know
the
the dude that that he had borrowed all
the money from he couldn't stop that
dude from like burning the barn down and
he couldn't like
you know so so the sun ends up following
them too but that's how
um that's how dan uh christian bale's
character
that's how he gets involved in
capturing risk because they there's they
come across like the stagecoach robbery
or whatever
and then ben seems to like i think he he
doesn't like he kind of like takes a
shine to dan i guess because he's he
knows he's like he sees that he's like
an honorable
guy so he doesn't like kill him or
anything like that
um and then but he but so ben ends up
getting caught eventually and
because of something that dan did he
kind of like kept him in one place until
the cops would get there and arrest him
and like i said he's the super famous
outlaw
so they're going to transport him
to this town called contention um and
they're gonna put him
on the 310 toyuma like to the prison
that's the the train that he's got to
get out to go to the prison so
so from like the first quarter of the
movie is kind of like build up like the
stagecoach
uh you know robbery and all that kind of
stuff and then they start
on the journey like where he's taking
like all the [ __ ] that happens like in
the gang is coming after
them like to rescue ben and everything
so and it's and it's just kind of like
uh oh and alan tudyk is in this as well
he's not in it that much
uh he plays like a doctor when they get
to this one town but
it's always good to see him you know
from firefly and uh
tucker and dale versus evil he was in
that as well but
but yeah so i i think the whole thing
it's almost kind of like the whole thing
was dan's quest to like
to kind of like raise himself in the
eyes of his family because i
i kind of feel like he his family kind
of looked at him like a failure
of a man you know what i mean because he
always did the right thing but he was
always getting [ __ ] on
by life and so
and the fact that like his wife and his
kids were just kind of like
so i think that he just wanted to show
that like you always have to do the
right thing
even if it costs you everything
which it does end up doing but
i guess because so i guess like he did
it all like for his son so his son could
be like hey my dad's awesome you know
what i mean so
i just really liked the the
juxtaposition like i said between his
character and russell crowe's character
russell crowe's character is like he's a
villain but he's also like kind of
like likeable yeah man i wish i was
russell crowe
not nowadays because i think he weighs
like 4 000 pounds yeah i guess
but [ __ ] russell crowe if i was
russell crowe i just [ __ ] throw
phones off like a day long i'd be
i'd see some i'd carry phones with me
and just sounds like a backpack
just throw a phone at somebody just at
random people
yeah i just go up to them i would just
like
every time i would go to a hotel i'd
just go to the front desk and i said can
i see the phone quickly they hand me the
phone just throw the phone
they're like what the [ __ ] let's set it
up so everyone get my buddy get his
camera
record this watch this excuse me can i
have the phone please thank you
you want to hear something sad you could
probably make a whole youtube channel
of just guy pretends he's russell crowe
throwing photos of people yeah
and you probably have like millions of
subscribers well you don't even have to
throw the phone at people
just throw the phone just you probably
shouldn't throw the photos
because then you'll get around every
time you give me a phone just tell the
receiver
it's gonna [ __ ] wire it [ __ ] it's on
the right that way be funny
it would kind of yeah i mean people
probably could get pictures
for breaking their phones you'd be
watching this the series to see me throw
the phone
it'd be the throw the phone show that's
the name of the show throw the phone
the phone throw the phone it's just all
one word
[Laughter]
crazy [ __ ] well and you could even like
change it up a little bit
like so you could like one show you
could kind of like pretend that you
weren't gonna throw the phone so it's
like there'd be suspense
you know what i mean
hey people have like dumber youtube
channels than that
like i was telling you last night i just
like i you know i
watched an hour long video of a girl
cleaning out her
gross refrigerator you know what i mean
it's like you know i wasn't just sitting
there watching it i was doing other
things too at the same time but it's
just kind of like i don't know there's
nothing like really compelling about
that
yeah but um all right so um
somebody said do do do do there's a
bunch of comments up there
yeah i know did anybody see the movie
snow piercer yes
uh yeah that was pretty good um
weirdest train movie i've seen is that
tom hanks animated one
i kind of want to watch that just
because i've seen clips of it and it's
like so
uncanny valley it like freaks me out i
saw i think um
welcome to the basement did a review on
it like around christmas time because
it's a christmas movie
and uh they were talking about how
atrocious it was and not just because
the animation is super weird looking but
they're also like the story is just kind
of like
lou hernandez was up in there and he was
saying that he didn't send this movie to
us
but it's a good movie yeah and then he
said i would like cop land he said it
was a great movie
yeah usually like i said i saw it in the
theater and that and i then i saw it
once subsequent like one time
subsequently so i've seen it a couple
times but it's been a long time
and grandpa's is in there for those who
don't know he's a guy went to high
school with he's a retired law
enforcement
now and uh he said that he wants applied
to the pinkerton
because it's uh the headquarters is up
there in michigan but they didn't they
didn't answer back
i didn't realize that they were still
around yeah and then um
yeah and he was just saying that the
cops of that era was just more like a
hard gun they were more like mercenaries
yeah yeah the sheriff was just a kind of
like an elected official for a town
and then he just hired basically
mercenaries
and deputized them those were the
deputies you know
but it's just a different way of hiring
the same kind of thing that would happen
now but
they didn't go to uh like
law enforcement training schools or
anything it was all
on the job training it was kind of like
nightclub bouncers with guns and horses
but some had military experience and
some of them had been you know
came from indian territory you know
some of them might have been indians or
half indian
um it's it's never really like what you
would think it would be if you go back
and you get some old books and you
actually look at the photos of the way
these guys looked
it it looks like a cross between mexico
and calif
old california and i don't know
the poverty level looked almost like
something out of india in a certain way
there's something always kind of
malnourished these they all looked kind
of malnourished
well they're all out there on the plane
and the prairie like eating hard tack
and [ __ ] like that
yeah i read beans and i don't think city
life for poor people was much better out
east
because uh there was other could i have
some more porridge sir and all that kind
of [ __ ]
they were those kind of people but there
was
they all looked malnourished to me real
narrow shoulders
skinny pot bellied skinny and pot belly
yeah and if they were old they were just
a belly
and it was just one big belly belly with
little stick arms and legs coming out of
it
i just thought of just like a whole
belly with just like the head down here
and
yeah you never never really could say
what they were eating you know like the
like the woman from slither they were
eating
bad stuff and and then you go he's an
old man and then you [ __ ] the age is
given underneath him he's like 35.
but he looks like about 65. yeah they
live [ __ ] real they didn't live long
put up wet as my grandma used to say and
the guys that were all fit were
in their teens and early twenties and
they looked pretty fit
and suits and [ __ ] running around
[ __ ] guns and suits and he's
aged like you know 25 but he looks like
a
35 year old a 45 year old almost it was
just a different era
everyone's very grizzled yeah
[Laughter]
rick shaw says midnight meat train is
the best trained movie i still got to
sit down and watch that i read this
story it's cloud barker in case anybody
didn't know
um and it's like i've always and i've
been wanting to see because
i feel like there's uh cl with clyde
barker stories the adaptations can like
they're either really really good or
really really
[ __ ] um and i've heard
that that one is really good and i keep
wanting to watch it and then i just keep
forgetting about it
um i think it's on tubey so i might get
around to like seeing it
um oracle says i believe the pinkertons
are now more of a high-tech security
firm
there's a branch of the agency in my
part of texas okay so see i didn't even
realize that they were still around
yeah that's kind of why um we want i've
been wanting to do a show about them
like i put it in the poll like the topic
poll a couple times but it didn't win
so i don't know maybe we can like we'll
do on one of these days or we can talk
about them on the side tracks or
whatever
they're in they're making all the
talking about the old west yeah
their diet was venison whiskey and heart
attack yeah probably
probably true prairie dogs and a bunch
of prairie dogs
that who knows uh
what kind of parasites they carried too
yeah probably
all had a lot of parasites and [ __ ] oh
yeah i imagine tape worms and stuff
because it's like you know it's not like
they had super clean water or
anything like that or good medical care
or
anything yeah can't guys say i think the
pinkertons run an armored car
cash delivery company company yeah
that's kind of what well that's kind of
in this movie that's what they were
doing except it was like a stagecoach
it was like an armored stage coach
wasn't it like yeah and they were taking
i don't know where they were going but
they were taking like money somewhere
and then
um i guess i didn't realize this when i
was watching it but i didn't i
when i read the wikipedia thing um you
know how at the beginning
like when uh hollander
like lets all of dan's cows out
those cows were what the gang
like they found the cows are like oh how
fortuitous and that that's what they use
like to block the road
yeah you know what i mean so yeah so
that's how the two of the big and that's
how they met up because dan was out
there looking for the cows
that the [ __ ] had let out of the barn
and that's when he came across
yeah the stagecoach thing and i was like
because i don't know for some reason
like i didn't link those two things in
my mind
until i was like reading the plot
synopsis but yeah um
i liked the movie it was a good western
um
i wouldn't say that it was uh like a
like a like epic legendary western it's
like not not on
not on par with like uh high plains
drifter or anything
but for a newer movie yeah it's good
real good
yeah and like i said this it's it's i
don't know if i'd necessarily call it a
remake because
it's just another adaptation because
there was one that came out in 1957
which like i said
um a lot of people seem to like that one
too um but i've never and some people
like you know esther said she likes that
one better
but i haven't seen that one but yeah
this one was like it's definitely like
more character
yeah driven it's like a more
character-driven western but that said
there's still like a lot of
uh gun fights and all kind of like crazy
[ __ ] happening in it so it's still like
exciting and it's pretty like well paced
and everything i wanted to say too it's
funny because 2007
was the same year there were like a
couple other westerns came out that year
too there was like um
what was that one uh the assassination
of jesse james
by the coward robert ford um and then
there was
one other one so i think like when he
was putting this one out he wanted to
like make sure
like he put it out before those other
two because he heard that there were all
these other westerns coming out he's
like oh [ __ ] i gotta be like
so he had to like put it out sooner
because i don't know it just seemed
really weird there seemed like a little
mini boom of
westerns for some reason in 2007.
it's hard to beat some of those clintus
wood westerns
well yeah i mean high plains drifter
and outlaw josie whales i could watch
those movies over and over and over
again
just the whole things are just a damn
meme in a way you know what i mean
every line in those movies is [ __ ]
epic
especially especially high plains
drifter which is
basically like the wild or the wild west
version of
of the crow this [ __ ] back from
the grave to get his vengeance
yeah and it's not totally obvious you
just have to pay close attention i
didn't realize it was
it was a supernatural story until i got
old enough to understand the symbolism
[ __ ] that it was doing
yeah i just thought it was yeah he's
killing this
because of what they did he doesn't look
exactly like the sheriff but that is the
sheriff
yeah yeah pretty cool phil says they had
a bar rag for the cowboys to wipe their
faces and they shared it and just passed
it down the line
they had such skin problems that's why
they wore mustaches yeah
well they're probably being out in the
[ __ ] weather all the time you just
like look like [ __ ]
leather they didn't have the the same
standards of physicality or sanitation
yeah they said the prostitution [ __ ]
situation was horrible you know in terms
of diseases and just uncleanliness
and just well yeah they didn't it was
the victorian era
people forget that this is the victorian
era so they had no
they had no sex education sex was
whatever they thought it was
i mean you can dig you can dig up
[ __ ]
1800s like in
wild west style porn and you're like
there's absolutely nothing sexy about it
it looks they look like
[ __ ] mug shots of the dead just some
naked chicks just laying there you know
that's that's that hey some like
necrophiles might be like oh
yeah yeah that was that was cowboy
well i guess you kind of had to take
what you could get it's not like it's
not like
it's not like they knew what they were
missing no necessarily no there was no
there was i saw uh um some commentary on
it from
psychologists and stuff and they were
kind of talking about the sexuality of
the time
and they said that they had no concept
of sexy
that that just wasn't that is a learned
behavior
like in other words like poses and [ __ ]
like that that was high-tech [ __ ]
and they think most of that the concept
of sexiness
really was a commercial effort from
corporations that was
selling packaging and booze booze
packaging and they would give these
saloons
paintings centered around booze and it
had
some girl in there and they've
eventually figured out that you had to
put them and start off with kind of
roman style
art poses roman and greco-roman style
but then it got slowly a little more
sexier over the time
and this is that's the only thing that
was the closest thing guys in the in the
old west and even probably in the united
states
that was the closest thing in the
victoria era victorian area that they
could ever get to say like
sex education that was that was their
sex education
it was just them paintings and saloons
yeah yeah weird
that was there was no porn industry
you had girls that get up on stage and
sing they called them stars but they
were huggers
but here's the thing
they're always showing the saloon with
women in it and that's
that's an inaccuracy women were not
allowed in saloons even the hookers were
not allowed
in the saloons the hookers were in the
brothel this is a dude only
area for some reason they had no problem
with
prostitution but they couldn't have
women in the bar
yeah but they had alcohol at the brothel
but the brothel was more kind of like a
hotel yeah with a parlor in the front of
it
so the whole thing about
these hookers hanging out in in the in
the casino
that's happening inside the bar nah that
didn't that wasn't
the way it was they kept all that [ __ ]
separate
that's pretty funny i thought it was
indecent to mix all that
except with the brothel that's fine but
it's like keep these ladies out of my
bar
well i think when they were making me
when they were shooting westerns in the
50s for television and stuff
and and the big in the screen the silver
screen for budgetary
reasons it's better to shoot all that in
one location yeah
you know because the average person
didn't know but no they didn't mix
booze and women
in the same spot
[Laughter]
oracle said there's a tv series uh you
might be interested in called dead still
about a victorian photographer who
specializes in photographing the
recently deceased
oh that sounds like right up my alley
i'm gonna have to where is it at is it
on like netflix or hulu or
something like that i'm gonna have to
check that out
yeah camp guy said i never had to tell
my kids anything they had seen it all on
tv in the movies by the time they were
eight or nine years old
and then uh phil was talking about uh
spittoons
yeah they didn't clean them they just
put sawdust on top of it the guys would
spit tobacco on the floor
that just makes me want to throw up just
like reading that honestly
but yeah all right so
it's on acorn i think oh okay so i'm
gonna have to look that up i'm gonna
look that up dead still
because that sounds that sounds really
good and something that i would
definitely
enjoy all right so
um bone tomahawk was awesome yeah
yeah we yeah we did a review of that a
while back right because we have that
actually they do
they do make some good westerns every
now and then just let's get they're
becoming rare
i liked there was one called what the
[ __ ] was the name of it
oh god damn it oh i'll probably think of
it in a minute nick cave wrote the
screenplay actually
um [ __ ] what the hell was the name of
that thing that was like really really
good
but um because he does a lot of music
like him and warren
ellis i feel like do a lot of music for
western type movies because he's like
really into those but yeah they have
made some really good ones some people
were saying earlier that they were
saying what their favorite westerns were
like true grit or you know the searchers
uh stuff like that but yeah yeah i
didn't see this
yeah because you know grit that's uh
that's uh john wayne yeah i think that's
john wayne
yeah yeah did somebody did somebody tell
me no
they didn't okay um i was trying to what
the [ __ ] was the name of that goddamn
movie i can't believe that i can't think
of it
[ __ ] out there going crazy they are yeah
um what is it western
yeah it came out back in
probably right around the time this did
or maybe like a little bit before
the [ __ ] was the name of that it was
like super super violent because of
course it was
because nick cave wrote it i didn't see
it i can't think of what the name of it
was
oh well i'll have to like the age pretty
well was unforgiving
well yeah i i kind of feel i really
really liked unforgiven yeah
it's pretty good sleazy b said i hate
westerns but likes this one called wild
bunch
yeah i feel like yeah i've seen that one
i feel like i've done
i've seen that one um yeah so it's weird
because i kind of feel like
it's easy b needs to see uh if you hate
westerns man you got to see high plains
drifter
because it's supernatural that's a
[ __ ] badass flick though
yeah i even like that like i said i'm
not a huge fan of westerns but
but now that i'm thinking about it i've
actually seen like a lot of really good
ones so what the hell am i even talking
about
even pale rider is pretty good yeah i'd
probably put it as
high plains drifter and then right
underneath that would be um
uh outlaw josie whales
and then unforgiven and then
pale ryder that's the order though
although the sergio leone ones were good
too they're just
it's kind of a different tone yeah the
good the bad and the ugly yeah
yeah all right so the proposition thank
you
i knew somebody would come up with it
was called the proposition thank you
very much
scoop dog because that was gonna drive
me crazy that i couldn't remember
because i really wanted because i wanted
to run out and see it because i was like
oh nick cave read it and i'm like a big
fan of him
so you know but yeah it was really good
like i said super violent
so is that all we have to talk about
because i'm kind of i'm
kind of sleepy to be honest with you
[Laughter]
all right so we will be back tomorrow
talking about some other movie which we
don't know what it is yet because we
haven't watched it
um so okay we'll have to we'll have to
watch
something we'll have to find some
tonight and talk about it tomorrow
that's what i'm saying
oh and also um we have to watch
basket case because that's going to be
our next
movie retrospective i know but like we
got to watch it again for the
for a review all right um but yeah
that's another frank cannon lottery it's
like same guy that did frankenhooker you
know what i mean that's
the same like director yeah so uh i've
seen basket case lots of times
but we're gonna uh watch that tonight
too or tomorrow night and then record it
all right so we'll be back tomorrow
talking about another movie
uh at 3 p.m eastern standard time in
case you didn't know
and uh that'll do it for today bye